just remember nobody wants the sub dick
but you have to give them saying oh [__]
here we go [__]
taking it back to the old school with
the old fool
get the [__] that I speak those models
out of this [__] today
[Music]
I got my flower I got my work I got a
woman who know oh [__] that's a little
sativa filly
there's 20 stars look how pretty that is
oh my goodness ladies and gentlemen no
way but I wrote on it
sure I love this [__] up here
[Music]
oh [__] it's a Monday night close that
door
[Music]
there you go that's not a spirit
[__] that's [__] let's
[__] reefer the same ghost and the
st. Michael Jackson
[Music]
this is uncle Joey on a Monday night
with his trusty little [__] Jewish
friend the ant I went ly sciatica
[__] around tonight if you got good
weed you better break it up tonight
lead I don't get [__] this is the
meal with death I said it's all right
[Music]
oh [__] midnight let me tell you some
I'd pop the pimple on my nose tonight is
squirted all over the mirror I haven't
had one like that since I was 18 years
old it was a [__] old coke rock the
[__] ginger oh my God look at it was
red I went back on the mirror I said
good googly moogly we're back and [__]
uncle Joey Monday March 20th you bad
[__] [__] you and st. Patty's
Day I've been smoking st. Paddy's as I
was 13 [__] I ain't a mother to anyway
we're here on a Monday night free church
and they get the reefer get the sleeping
pills drink the night we'll get the
[__] benadryl I don't give a [__]
what you do it's your lucky night if
you're on the a-team hang up now
[Music]
hahaha and guess who's here by [__]
audience requests the Savage is back
how are you mr. savage I'm fine how are
you guys we got a bunch of dead [__]
puppets that's the tooth that's 1968
we're showing up with pipes with faces
hello how are you
ah I got perennial I got tangerine dream
I got [__] uh what's the other one I
got the Le Conte LA Confidential
and look at this [__] butter death
I've been saving this for about two
years you understand me it's from the
one I jus there's not one of his
smuggling trips into this oh oh [__]
we're back [__] it's your lucky
night get the you potato clock lotto
maybe you hit those three numbers but it
don't matter you look the luckiest day
your life was the day you ran over that
[__] dog you [__] get your
[__] together
it's Monday night the church coming at
you we got a good show Lee's going deep
deep deep into the murky waters you
don't saying this cuz I'm on went leaves
a Jew they don't let in your world so
get the eatin [__] training
commences tonight and we will do the
countdown I'll be your dick Clark you
know say ten nine eight seven
[Music]
oh [__] the roots hates God you know
this sometimes the HD is on fire but
sometimes the [__] smoke goes into
the lenses there I gotta provide Xena in
that [__] you understand me
that's how strong the smoke is you
[__] [__] get it together
it's Monday night [__] Church coming
at you it's a good week turn on your
DVRs right now the High Court I'm
blowing [__] clouds there's a [__]
that leaves a lot of leg it's a good
episode what else I got nothing else
Nyack New York next week you bad
[__] it's time lease for a bong
is there's a good bond tonight Lee
cleaned we call this the moon the mule
junior but he [__] crazy glued the
thing so that's a complete different
situation this is the eyeball of death
you see I'm saying we had a lot of
[__] toys here this is the poker here
you [__] who's better than you guys
man who's better than you want a [__]
Monday night no Monday night will should
we give Lee let's give me this [__]
death trap over here is a death trap mm
I can't let you go
the cops are coming to aid me
[__] we were smoking something
different listen all right get your
hands in the air like you just don't
care [__] it's lead time for the
first bong of the debt you don't want to
train look at them you don't want to
train on the weekends I tried you mm you
saw her time mm yeah you kept reading
it's just spitting them out and reading
somebody told her
I step on a debt w ee [__] around the
mule ain't [__] around tonight I don't
know what you thinkin the mule is
nothing dunya this [__] thing if you
say well he gave assistance [__] the
third grade things would have been
different the mule is a savage he still
coughing drink some water that's just
the first one we're gonna do a hit of
this [__] got a heap of Hiva God you
know I'm saying that's what we call this
we got ten starts for the it's over
that's what happens I tell my son you
better smoke on the weekend you don't
want to smoke one three you got about an
ounce in your house [__] I've been
trying to listen I don't give a [__]
what you hear this we won't listen if
uncle Joey ain't got it it ain't
happening
this is the [__] that kills animals is
[__] you ever see when you go to the
thing animals would use to Tet the same
thing this thing killed like 18 goats
last week this we did understand meow
he's showing up at some [__]
Susquehanna and then we show up with the
mule and the savage are you gonna how
you got how the [__] you gonna act you
know you're gonna be [__] up like
Judeans I drew Delray what's his name
Dean Delroy [__] around here guys
when I go to the store they all wave at
each other blinking bow in the back room
cuz they know this ain't it you can't
give this to these Gentiles up here they
[__] flabbergast
it took me when I'm along with my
running four or five years through a
bond out of the meal look at him he's
Belle his head was red sweating that's
what we got here and the Voodoo Lounge
you've entered the Voodoo [__] lounge
oh [__] oh [__] [__]
and always remember the sugar cubes are
looking like your lungs come back let me
say something you hang out with me for
two years your lungs will never make a
comeback you understand I've been
hypnotized glommit eyes doctor beliefs
I'm still huffing and puffing the damage
is done [__] what do you think
time for a bong hit what do you want to
do guys it's up to you you know I'm
saying I'm a slave to you guys get the
[__] out of here what do you want to do
let's do the [__] let's do the savage
it won't be long - nine oh [__] is a
scary [__] jam right here tool does
the best cover of it let me tell you
something Led Zeppelin there's still the
[__] Kings to write this song at a
slope 22 of these bong hits you
understand me just to write this [__]
jam oh [__]
I'm Tanya
the final frontier is soon but if you
watch the periscope if you eat your
vegetables if you do your push-ups
you're gonna be alright guys
[__] don't even watch the news no more
listen I'm done even world news tonight
I had to tap out about two weeks ago I'm
done I'd rather write than [__] watch
that and let all that [__] go into your
mind you don't need it don't matter
listen go out the yard dig your trench
like ten foot
prepare yourself and catch some nuclear
bomb you got cookies and [__] down there
for a few weeks and then I don't know
what the [__] to tell you about don't
watch the news don't hurt it had to come
to an end man it's just [__] terrible
[__] for the first 19 minutes that who
gives a [__] listen you got to get up in
the morning and take care you that's it
what do you do this is a micro economic
[__] business you want to join UNICEF
and give bags of rice to Chinese people
yeah get on the plane nobody left nobody
said they were leaving nobody left we
don't know Stars be eating you ain't eat
them I'm watching you like a hawk you
throwing him away and [__] he hates to
10,000
anyway we'll be back in about [__] 15
minutes 20 minutes whatever the [__] we
gotta recoup from this [__] mental
anguish look at the eyeballs I do you
think of those [__] things this is
the real deal tonight podcast sponsored
by who tonight me undies and seaso me
undies keeping your nutsack
amia way
[Music]
yeah go out there see how anyway we want
the you I saw another ball that [__]
mule was strong tonight dice and we're
finished [__]
[Music]
listen I don't know nothing about
nothing while I smoke a reefer I like
just getting high now I don't even think
I'll go back to edibles that's how
stoned I'm going I'm going back to
basics you understand me
but anyway youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz ten minutes I'm gonna drink a
little water and get my [__] together
here you understand me because I am
there this reef will take you there go
to perennial tomorrow has come for the
hell a confidential that's all you need
to [__] know take as much as you can
take it home put half of it away in case
we got hit with a missile you just at
least you're the last man standing and
smoke on the best reefer units Tami you
know yeah i when you start into me and
no starts twitching you haven't done
blowing 10 [__] years
anyway don't forget about me go take the
[__] High Court let me know what you
think you know I love you [__]
proving to you you'd have to be
good-looking or built like a champion as
long as you got to hanging between your
[__] legs you can do whatever the
[__] you want you understand me that's
it that's it and that's that Willie
Barcena is here Lisa adds here we'll be
back in 10 minutes [__]
would you go start